We've just reviewed a bit of new material on the shape of a function and how
that's affected by its degree, and also how changing the sign of the
coefficient flips the graph over the x axis. Now, I've drawn four different
graphs here, and labeled them a, b, c, and d. They represent 4 types of
functions which I've listed right here. One of them shows a polynomial with an
even degree and a positive leading coefficient. One shows a polynomial with an
even degree and a negative leading coefficient. Another shows a polynomial with
an odd degree and positive leading coefficient. And the last one shows a
polynomial with odd degree and a negative leading coefficient. I'd like you to
tell me which one of these graphs matches each of these categories. Please put
the letter of each graph next to the description over here that it matches.